hey guys how's it going I'm Justine and
today we're going to be unboxing the new
EU sn5 I'm excited about this because I
had the m3 which was their previous
version and I loved so many things about
that and this is the upgraded version
I'll also be taking it outside do a
little more comprehensive test so stay
tuned for that later in this video but
without further ado let's unbox this so
that we can get into the fun stuff
quicker the first thing we've got is the
battery charger just judging by the look
of this it looks like it is the same
charger as the m3 which will be great
because I'll be able to use the charger
from my previous version and also the
battery we've got a USB mini here's our
battery the camera strap and here's what
we've all been waiting for the body take
a sweet look at this so I absolutely am
so into this matte black finish that
they have here this one kind of sets
itself apart if you can tell by this
color I'm not really sure what color I
want to call it like a gunmetal type of
color but it's still a nice matte black
shiny silver it looks really good sort
of things that also makes this camera
slightly more unique than some of the
previous versions is I haven't seen a
Canon camera that does this the LCD
screen folds down so this is such a
better placement than when it folds up
because a lot of times I'll have a
microphone or light or something on
there and this just gets in the way so
the only thing that I can see this
interfering with is if you're shooting
on a tripod or something like that but
you will still be able to fold it down
to be able to see enough of what you
need to see well most of these cameras
you are able to connect them to your
phone so you're actually able to use
this as a second viewfinder which I do
for almost all of my videos when I'm
shooting anything even like this one
because it's far away so I can actually
see what I'm seeing on my phone this on
a camera so you basically can use your
phone as a viewfinder camera inception
you're also able to view and save images
and videos directly from your phone
scroll up here I think save these
pictures directly to my phone directly
from camera to Instagram in seconds so
let's pop a battery in here take this
for a test spin so the lens that I would
probably recommend getting if you don't
want to switch lenses out very often is
this is 18 to 150 this gives you a wide
enough range that you'll be able to zoom
in and get some shots that are far away
but it will be far away enough when
you're vlogging to still sort of beat
yourself in frame now I love being able
taps from the wide angle lens view which
is why I can't wait to try this one this
is the 1122 so this will give you a much
wider view if you're vlogging and this
one over here is the 15 to 45 so this
will give you a little less of the
fisheye look
so there's a lot of different things
that you can do with so many different
lenses and that's gonna really impact
how you shoot your videos and what you
carry with you while we're on topic with
lenses this is the EF EOS m mount
adapter with this you can attach it
right to your m5 if you already have a
bunch of other Canon lenses this will
allow you to attach them right to this
guy also got a little additional tripod
mount here especially if you're using
huge lenses and it needs the extra
stability we've just turned this thing
into a monster
so this afm mount will allow all of your
EF and ef-s lenses to be compatible with
AOS m5
so right here's a little lock setting
that's actually kind of cool so you have
to push this as it's telling you here to
push this forward and then you rotate to
start using the camera so one of the
best things about this camera is it's
small enough to take with you everywhere
you go but it also has audio input
especially because you never know what
scenario you're going to find yourself
out when you're vlogging you're filming
so these are the two microphones that
I've currently been using this one is a
cute little rode microphone and this is
a canon specific DME one microphone hook
they recently released this year the
best part about this little guy is you
don't need a battery for it you
basically plug it in and it works but
it's extremely directional so unless
you're filming and you need the audio
directly in front of you that's
basically all you're going to get this
guy is exclusive to Canon but it gives
you several different options it gives
you shotgun 90 degrees and 120 degrees
audio it also has this little Auto
button which I absolutely love so as
long as it's on auto and it's plugged in
I know it's going to get the job done
I'm pretty excited to take this outside
and play hey guys so today I'm testing
out a camera it is a quite a nice camera
it's the USM 5 by Canon and it's pretty
cool so I'm excited to test this out I'm
going to go out for a test vlog so here
we are testing testing testing
here's our first lens test this is the
11 to 22 we're here at the dog park
oh we're not testing out the 18 to 150
millimeter lens this lens will allow you
guys to zoom a lot more
and if the Laplanders
tapping out this is a 15 to 45
millimeter let's see how the dog park
you
another feature that I've been really
into is time-lapse movie mode so
basically you can just combine all these
images that are shot into a single movie
I took it down to the beach to get a
nice sunset time-lapse shot I shot this
with two second intervals and it got it
right as the Sun went down
you
so I've been using this camera for about
a week now I have several videos on my
channel but you guys didn't even know I
was vlogging with this camera I'll put
links in the description if you guys
want to go check those out for a full
look at what it looks like to vlog for a
full day on this little guy prudential
past week i've been traveling around
with these three lenses the one that
i've been mostly been using is this one
right here this is the 11 to 22 it gives
you enough zoom to zoom into things that
are a little bit further away but it
also gives you a really nice wide angle
shot of yourself the second lens that
i've been using is this 18 to 150 if you
saw in some of the vlogs i got some
really long shots of my dog at the dog
park that's what i use this little guy
for and a focus on it was extremely
quick it was a lot faster than i thought
it was going to be so i've been mostly
using this for vlogging so the flipped
on string that goes this way is actually
really good if you're just holding your
camera like this because even if you do
look down it doesn't actually look like
you're not looking at the lens which is
something that drives me crazy about
vloggers the lens is where you need to
look so you do use this camera on a
tripod you might run into a little bit
of an issue i can still fold this down
and be able to see enough of the screen
to zoom in focus or see what i need to
see but if you do have a larger tripod
there's a good chance that you won't be
able to see much of the screen so that
was really the only thing that I even
ran into at all with his camera
I'm usually extremely picky about
vlogging cameras they have to have good
audio they have to be able to zoom and
autofocus quickly so for me I think this
is gonna be pretty much my new on-the-go
vlogging camera a little bit bigger than
the g7x but it's definitely smaller than
the AVD so that makes it pretty much fit
right in that sweet spot that I can pair
this into my purse a lot of times the
onboard audio with these cameras aren't
as good as I'd like but surprisingly
this was pretty good if you don't use a
microphone you're still okay but since
this does have an audio input I
definitely recommend it because it will
increase your audio significantly well
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
guys have any questions about this
camera feel free to ask me those in the
comments below
and hopefully I can help you guys out
I'll see you guys in the next video that
tripods I've got all kinds of things in
here so a lot of you guys thought that
these cords were everything that I need
to make this MacBook Pro actually
functionable so far I've paired it down
to one USB C hub a USB C to Thunderbolt
adapter a USB C
powered hard drive and the fourth chord
I'm using